now next it is time for us to review the
things that you want us to this is
actually audience members send in these
questions for Drew's reviews
oh today we're digging into the show
that everyone is talking about and just
like that it's the return of the Sex in
the City we thought we knew
we thought we knew and you know the
cultural institution that started 23
years ago the first two episodes are out
and oh my god did you watch them finally
I did okay and we have not discussed
this yet and clap of hands how many
people know what happened
okay it's out there okay clap of hands
who doesn't want a spoiler alert
not enough you're getting one okay
um big dies at the end of the pilot on a
Peloton what yeah yeah I know Peloton
stocks immediately plummeted yeah
um people freaked out Peloton through
every penny they had at doing a
commercial overnight with big and Ryan
Reynolds voice over it is going big is
still alive this is all kind of let's
make light of this insane situation and
then all of a sudden there is so much
scuttlebutt about why Carrie didn't just
call 9-1-1 well come on now she did she
did she should have called 9-1-1 there
really wasn't a lot of time yet that's
when you focus this is crunch time
Carrie grab your phone grab your phone
three numbers nine one one I'm just
worried that everyone's gonna be like
yeah I really shouldn't work out because
it's gonna kill me
well no well he also was smoking a cigar
right before he worked out so you know
do the math you know what I mean I can
we just talk about though
we have invested so much time so many
years in Carrie and her happiness with
Mr Big And in the first episode of it
just like that we get about three and a
half minutes of seeing them happy and
then
he dies
El Peloton we couldn't have just a
little moment just to Revel in them
could I have two episodes three episodes
of refining happiness here's what I will
say what they didn't have a boring
writer's room that's for sure you know
what you know what
kudos to when it comes to business and
filmmaking and I know a thing or two
about this because I've been producing
since I was 19 and we've made lots of
movies and television shows and we
produce this show when you can create
this kind of water cooler phenomenon
yeah I just don't know where this is all
going but I do applaud them for
providing a ride that we were not
prepared for yeah I am that is not easy
to do because they're going to come out
as this Legacy Show everybody's going to
be watching your every move and judging
it and tearing it apart and they gave us
a real Whopper I did I missed Samantha
though give me a blonde wig and I'll
just show I'll show up like this hi
ladies I'm back here's what I love is
how sentimental you are about this and
how business pragmatic I am I know this
you're like oh but this not I'm like
stocks are crashing writer's rooms are
on fire I know I really was really
emotional about it okay why may I ask
why am I dead inside and why is this
affecting you so much I mean because I
missed my friends you know it was really
good to see everybody I don't know you
but a hi Carrie Bradshaw and I just I I
don't I needed it I needed like to have
like a it's been such a hard time like
sitting around with my girlfriends in a
cosmo kind of feels like the exact
antidote I need and I kind of live
vicariously through them
um okay so I guess really what we're
gonna do for the Drew's reviews as
always is we do
um out of five stars what would you rate
it Rossi what's your rating well they
broke my heart but I was thoroughly
entertained so what three and a half out
of five stars
yeah what what do you give it what
it's weird
I'm not great
I loved every second of it except for
when they killed Mr big I mean I loved
it I'm obsessed I watched every episode
but how dare you how dare you
um I'm gonna give it a like 10 000 out
of five stars because I have that many
feelings about it whoa
[Music]
foreign